>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>>KAREN JAFFE: Hi, good morning.
>> Good morning.
>>KAREN JAFFE: Good morning.
[inaudible] both schools in
the District of Columbia.
And you guys are grade
kindergarten, right?
>> Yeah.
>>KAREN JAFFE: Thank you.
we're very glad to have you.
you are in the Library of Congress.
Has anyone been to the
Library of Congress before?
>> Yeah.
>>KAREN JAFFE: A few of you, great.
Welcome back.
And you're in a special
place in the Library
of Congress called the
Young Readers Center.
I'm Karen Jaffe, I'm director
of the Young Readers Center.
And I'm here to welcome you
for something called,
"kids Euro Festival."
Here's what that is.
Kids Euro, Euro stands
for European unit.
Which is made up of 28
countries in Europe.
Very far away.
Has anybody heard of Europe?
>> No.
>> Okay. Europe is across a very big
ocean, called the Atlantic Ocean.
And these 28 countries have a
festival in Washington every year
for children, just for children,
and they invited special performers
who come to show you things
they do in their country
and to tell you about their country.
And today the country
is called Luxemburg.
And here's a map and there
are two words up there,
one is the English word
and the other is the --
I think that's the French word.
But they speak three
languages in Luxemburg.
They speak German, French and
Luxemburgish, [inaudible].
The other language.
But that's a map of where it is.
Okay. So, I'm going to introduce
our special guest who's called the
Drummond from Luxemburg.
>> SVEN KIEFER: I'm doing nothing.
Nowhere, I put my rhythm,
that's not rhythm.
That's not [inaudible].
It's not [inaudible].
I was looking for my rhythm.
Rhythm. Rhythm.
No, no, that's still paper.
It's still paper.
Oh, my gosh.
Is there somebody out there?
You sure, hello?
Hello? Hello?
Oh, there's somebody out there and
I do not find my rhythm, no, no.
oh, no, no, no.
somebody's out there.
I have to take a look there.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Hi, guys.
How are you?
you're fine?
Yes? Oh, please come near.
Come, come.
You can come, everybody
can come nearer.
Don't be scared, come
nearer where you will see.
I wanted to show you something.
Do you know what is rhythm?
>> Me.
>> SVEN KIEFER: you
see rhythm one time.
No, stay there, everybody
will see it.
do you know rhythm?
No, no. you don't know who I am.
You do not know who I am.
No. your teacher doesn't
tell you where you know.
Wait. You don't know what's my name.
you know my name.
what's my name?
>> I don't know.
>> You don't know.
Your teacher doesn't
tell you the name?
good job, huh?
Wow, I'm Drummond [inaudible].
Say hi, Drummond [inaudible]
one time.
Good, okay.
Let's go. I want to show you rhythm.
Did you teacher show
you the rhythm one time?
No. oh, my god, what
did you do there.
Wow, no rhythm at all?
Nothing? Wow.
But, you see my golden tent?
Yeah. I think you see that.
So, that's for the teachers now,
when I bring something
out you have to clap.
Do you know how to clap actually?
Yeah, you know how it works.
Oh, great, good, wow.
I do know where I put my rhythm.
That's not rhythm that's stupid box.
No, no, no, no, no.
still. Now, for this
you don't have to clap,
but I wanted to show rhythm, rhythm.
Because rhythm is something
really fantastic.
Rhythm? I think there's
nothing inside, yeah?
I don't know where I put that.
Maybe the seat on the bum on rhythm.
Check underneath under
your bum, is there rhythm?
No. what's here?
Rhythm. No.
and there.
Do you have rhythm underneath?
No. everybody, check it one time.
Good morning, Victoria,
do we have rhythm?
No. Why? And grownups
people sit there.
Great great.
It's for everybody.
Every act to move your bum
big, and where's rhythm.
Oh, you no you do.
Please, take a seat.
No, no rhythm.
Yeah, you smiling, I'm
coming to you as well, huh?
There's no rhythm.
Check that please.
Check everybody.
No rhythm.
You sure? Okay, don't move.
What's going on.
The rhythm?
No. take picture for Facebook.
Oh, my god.
no rhythm at all huh?
Oh, we didn't check there?
Is there some rhythm underneath?
No. maybe I didn't check the bag.
I forgot to check the bag.
Because rhythm is something
[inaudible] This is something.
Don't feel bad.
It's getting boring
with all this paper.
But, oh, my god.
No, no, no, no, no, don't
do it, behind the red line.
Stay behind the red line.
Oh. This is not rhythm.
What's that, you know that?
It's a piece of a coconut.
Did you show a coconut before?
No. These teachers,
look at [inaudible].
It's a coconut.
But it's not rhythm.
No, no. I would say, okay,
we cannot see a rhythm.
Maybe we can smell it.
does everybody have a nose?
>> Yeah.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Everybody,
you're sure?
Is it clean?
Yeah. A little bit.
Trying to get a good smell.
[sniffing] somebody smell
something like rhythm.
[kids chattering inaudibly]
You smell the rhythm?
I do not smell the rhythm.
Do it again.
I come over here.
Let's do it again.
[sniffing] I smell a fart, huh?
Oh, my god.
oh. But it's not rhythm.
So, I would say, you cannot
see it, you cannot smell it,
maybe we can listen to it.
You have ears like me?
That's right.
You know the bubble game?
>> SVEN KIEFER: I hear nothing.
Nothing at all.
So, rhythm, nothing to see,
nothing to smell, nothing --
I know a game help
us find the rhythm.
Please, Congress of Library,
everybody stand up now.
so, be behind the red line.
Go a little bit back.
A little bit in the back.
Everybody needs a little
bit of space.
You need more space.
You there.
Okay. you know what is a freeze?
When you make freeze you make
a cool movement and you stay
and you don't move anymore.
You are frozen, okay.
It's for everybody.
You paid the entrance, it's
for everybody, it's free.
You will see.
You don't come here to sit nice.
See, he will do the job, huh?
It's okay, everybody
can [inaudible] today.
This is free.
Okay, you okay, you feel good?
Sure. We will jump now
and when I shout stop,
everybody freezing, okay?
we do that, ready.
You can jump.
You are sure.
Let's go for jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump, jump.
That's good.
Freeze.
So, that's the moment for the
teachers, hi, teachers, hello,
hey guys, would you
make some pictures?
It's nice to see.
You have a phone there.
Okay, let's do some pictures.
Hey, we do it again I think, huh?
They have to organize it,
picture, camera, oh, my god.
okay, we jump again.
Hey, people, you come
from Washington?
It was that high.
Could you jump more high?
Let's try.
Come on. Jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump.
And freeze.
Don't move.
Don't move at all.
take a look to the camera.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Maybe it's
good to stay on that side,
please behind the red line.
Okay, but you forgot something.
>> Can we do it again?
>> SVEN KIEFER: We
have to do it again,
because you forgot
to find the rhythm.
We do that again.
Okay, ready?
Okay, we jump, make freeze
and then we open our eyes
and we close our mouth again, and
maybe we hear something, okay?
that is difficult, you can do that?
Yeah. Okay, okay.
you ready with the camera now.
please, jump, jump, jump, go.
Freeze.
>> SVEN KIEFER: I hear nothing.
I have an idea.
You know where you prep for
this, inside your stomach.
Put your hands on your stomach.
On your breakfast.
And then you make 1, 2, 3
and here something bumping.
Hey, it's also for you there.
It's free.
No, you don't have to pay for this.
you feel something inside there.
Yeah. You sure?
What do you feel?
>> Your heart.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Your heart.
It's bumping along
huh, bump, bump, bump.
Take a seat, take a seat.
On the other side, please.
Take a seat.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Take a seat.
That's good.
Do you know the rhythm is
coming from your heart,
because your heart can
do something magical.
Like when you sleep -- don't
fight for place, everybody looking
to me -- when you sleep
your heart can do that.
Bump, [snoring].
>> SVEN KIEFER: Bump.
[snoring] Bump.
When you wake up in the
morning you take a breath first.
Bump, bump, bump.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
You are going a little bit faster
and you go to the playground
and jump around, bump,
bump, bump, bump, bump.
For sure. Take a look at your
heart again, feel that again.
Is it the same fast as it was
before or is it slower now.
it's slowing down a lot, huh?
Wow. This is magic.
Actually do you know the
first instrument in the world?
No. these teachers, what
are you doing all the time.
The first instrument,
you never showed them?
No? I will show you.
oh, wait, I have to
organize my mess here.
You see that mess.
You ready for the first,
very very first instrument
at all in the world.
Ready to see that?
You really want to see that?
No, don't do that.
You really sure you want to see
the first instrument in the world?
Sure. Yeah.
Yes. You want to see it.
the first instrument
in the world, yeah.
You ready for the first
instrument in the world at all?
ready to clap, ready.
Here comes the first
instrument in the world.
[ Clapping ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: [inaudible].
Imagine how old I look like when
I'm very old, like beard like that.
No, it was the body.
Your body.
We are going to do
something together.
But we have to half a
meter back, everybody.
Just a little bit, everybody.
Everybody need a little
bit of space.
Too near, too near,
just a little bit back.
A little bit back.
Just a bit, just a bit, just a bit.
Yes. Okay.
everybody has space.
Just a little bit back.
Thank you.
thank you.
don't fight.
Good. Okay.
you see my [inaudible]
oh, what's up you.
stand up please.
I invite you to stand up, everybody.
They have to stand up as well.
Oh, my god.
you're tired, coming
here, nice performance.
Now, it's huge.
Please take a look to my
[inaudible], that's my [inaudible].
You see my [inaudible]?
Everybody look to my [inaudible].
When my [inaudible] moves
like that m make a sound.
You see, with the foot.
You see again.
Okay. everybody understand,
we do it together.
Take a look.
It doesn't move at all,
it doesn't move at all.
take a look, we go and boom.
Not bad. We do it again.
Take a look to my [inaudible]
and we move.
Boom. Surprise.
Can we clap one time.
We get that?
No, no, no.
one time. Can you count one?
You can count to one.
Clap together, you look
to me, take a look to me.
[clap] Again, again.
Ready? [clap] last time, you ready?
[clap] I didn't clap at all.
again. Okay, now we gone,
now we go, most difficult.
Take a look.
[inaudible] meets foot.
Surprise. Clap and then foot.
And foot, and clap.
And your foot and clap,.
And foot and clap.
Yeah, woo.
Take a seat.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Wow.
No problem.
Okay. but, after doing that
a while, it can be boring.
I have first instrument
-- no, leave it.
do you want to see
the first instrument.
But, first, it's -- what -- the
first instrument such a small story,
I have to tell you, are you
ready for first instrument.
Yeah. Are you ready?
Are you sure?
Yeah. Hey, teachers,
what's going on?
[ Applause ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Okay, I understand.
That was a tree.
Yes, it was.
And a big tree, but it was not
blue like me, it was a tree.
And there was a farmer and the
farmer -- no, no, wait, wait,
try to do that bump again.
I tell you a small story.
This farmer came out one
day and he was very angry,
and he was so angry
he came with a saw
and with the saw he
cut off the tree.
He was still so angry that
he made a hole inside.
It's magic and made
a big hole inside.
On this farm he had lots of mice.
Anyway, do you know how a cow
make, the cows, how they do?
>> Moo.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Moo.
So, you have cows in Washington.
Moo. Do you know how a horse make?
>> Neigh.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Neigh.
Okay. and the farmer he has a coat
and this was goat was
all day bah, bah, bah.
But the goat died.
There was nobody there
that was talking anymore,
because the goat was not there.
The farmer got a great idea.
He took the coat off the goat
and he put it on his tree.
He took a long, long, long, long,
long, long rope, that is going up,
down, up, down, up, down, up,
down, up, down, up, down, up, down.
now, Washington, I have a question,
can you make a look at something
without taking and using hands.
You can look with your
eyes, you can do that?
Sure, take a look inside.
You see, it's a big hole inside.
I told you that.
No, with your eyes.
You see it?
You saw it.
everybody got it.
now, take a look at
how I catch a goat.
No, no, It's a goat.
To catch a goat you need
a rope, a long rope.
You got it.
so, then you put the
rope underneath,
and then you have a
small for the flop.
Bend your knees and your
[inaudible] in-between there,
and your hands in-between
there and maybe, don't touch,
maybe you have it like that.
Thank you, thank you.
so, are you ready.
Please, close your ears.
Ready? Huh?
Ready?
[ Drum Sounds ]
[ Applause ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Now, try
a little bit sit down,
listen, make the bubble game.
I tell you a story with my drum.
[ Drum Sounds ]
[ Kids screaming ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: I think you
can do something together.
Please, stand up, stand up.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
It's difficult.
It's really hot in this.
shows are really hot.
Stand up, sit down,
stand up, sit down.
okay, you.
place it on the ground.
You cannot jump.
You just can wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Stay behind the line.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
No, I thought wiggling would
be like that, you know.
Wiggle, jiggle jiggle.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle.
Please move your body.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle what's going on there.
Back seats.
Wiggle, wiggle wiggle,
no, don't want to wiggle?
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle.
wiggle, wiggle Oh, wait.
Can you do two things
at the same time?
You think, yeah, you can do that.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle,
clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Wiggle, clap, wiggle, clap.
Wiggle, clap, wiggle, clap, wiggle,
clap, wiggle, clap, wiggle, clap,
wiggle, clap, wiggle,
clap, wiggle, clap.
[ Drum Sounds ]
Wiggle, clap, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, clap.
Hey, not bad.
Wow. You make some fun, yeah.
Okay? you heard about my country,
now you have to learn the word --
please -- you have to
learn a word in my country.
In my country we have
some nice word it's called
"poopusvinken" [assumed spelling].
Try to say poopusvinken.
>> Poopusvinken.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Poopusvinken.
Very important when
you go to my country.
You can't say hello.
Poopusvinken, do you know that?
Can you spell it, poopusvinken,
can you say it one
time for me, teachers.
Poopusvinken.
All right.
I explain to you now
what poopusvinken is now.
it's the best part in this show.
You ready for poopusvinken there?
Put out your bum and
show it to your teacher.
That's the poopus we call.
To the teacher to the
camera, put it out.
So, and now you make the wiggle.
That's poopusvinken.
Now you understand
how poopusvinken is.
But, we do now three things.
Three things.
We wiggle, we wiggle, we
wiggle it, we waggle it.
still we wiggle.
You ready with the camera.
You wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
then we clap, clap, clap,
wiggle, wiggle, poopusvinken.
Poopusvinken, poopusvinken.
Yeah. Now you make
poopusvinken and wiggle.
You move your bum.
Move your bum.
Poopusvinken, poopusvinken.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Yu like that?
So, now it's for you.
you make the film,
you ready, your bum,
nobody will see your
bum, just put it there.
Ready, wiggle, you wiggle, make
it faster now, it's funnier.
Ready? Wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, clap, clap, clap,
clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Poopusvinken, poopusvinken,
poopusvinken.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Yeah.
Woo. But you can take
a seat shortly.
Not everybody in the
world had this nice drum.
Some people over the big
ocean they had something very,
ooh, they had this big box.
Oh, teacher's please.
Oh, my gosh.
Don't look, play attention here.
Yeah. It's a big box and in
the big box would be a hole.
You see. Take a seat.
Wait, wait.
Listen, listen.
SpongeBob.
[ Children speaking inaudibly ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: There's
nobody inside.
Nobody inside.
No, it's empty.
It's empty.
Maybe I can sit on that.
Shall I hit it one time?
Yeah, you think.
To hit that thing.
Whoa. That was a great idea.
[ Pounding Noise ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Hey, Washington,
in my country the people can do
four things at the same time.
Are you sure you can try.
They can do four things
at the same time.
Yeah. You think you can do that.
Let's try it.
Stand up, please.
Four things in one moment.
Now it's a show.
Wow. Stay behind.
Okay. ready?
First step.
And take a look at the
camera for Facebook.
Especially for you,
especially for you,
who's behind me, no, it's for you.
okay. ready.
First thing is the wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
And wiggle.
Clap and wiggle, two things.
Two things.
Wiggle and clap.
And now we make poopusvinken
as well.
So we clap, we wiggle,
we poopusvinken
and then we try to circle around.
Whoa, four things.
You ready to do that?
It's a lot.
Suppose to be a lot.
You see some people don't
move, they still sit.
It's amazing.
Ready? Four things to do, yeah.
No, stay behind.
Thank you.
okay, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap,
poopusvinken, poopusvinken,
poopusvinken, turn around,
turn around, turn around.
Poopusvinken, turn around,
clap, clap, clap, clap.
Woo.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Oh my gosh.
Oh, that was too much.
Take a seat, take a seat.
And after, don't do that.
After all this history,
stay back, please.
After all this history there was
this great big moment in life
because they -- no,
that's okay, that's okay.
you pay attention now.
it's great, it's great.
But for now I invite
a special guest.
The world famous drummer
[inaudible].
Are you ready to welcome with
me the world famous drummer?
He's inside there,
world famous drummer.
You want to see him?
Yeah, man.
Are you ready for clap.
Here is the world famous
drummer of all.
[ Applause ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: And
for you special guest.
Please more of that.
Woo. Now, take a look.
I see, great.
[ Bunny drumming ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: He can as
well as doing poopusvinken.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Not bad, huh?
No. behind.
So, after all this history now.
What's your name, Cody, go back.
Sometimes there are many rules,
rules sometimes are very difficult.
You people build something,
it's the coconut.
Take a look to my coconut.
Go back. The coconut,
you see the coconut?
Listen to that.
I will join you in melody.
Because after all sometimes
melodies are great.
Listen, are you ready?
[ Various clicking sounds ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Sometimes
music is strange, huh?
Maybe mom and dad [inaudible]
sometimes strange.
But, people build all the times
instruments and then they get that.
A xylophone, that's right.
this is a very old xylophone.
Do you know what they did in
the time with these things
in the winter, in the winter
they through it [inaudible].
Yeah. Shall I try?
>> SVEN KIEFER: Ready?
Sure? Is the phone on.
You going to make a whole
film of mine, or what.
I get famous in America, yeah.
I'm so glad that I shaved.
Okay, let's growing
up people sometimes.
Ready for the melody?
Wait. Something's not right.
okay. I think [inaudible].
Ah, I play you Luxemburg
melody, okay.
>> SVEN KIEFER: I can't.
>> SVEN KIEFER: No, wait.
Look. There's a big
one and then a small.
So, where to start.
Ah. You know where.
Big one or small one?
Big one, small one.
What do you think?
What do you think, big or small?
Middle one, no, no.
big or small?
Small, big.
I'm big. I start with big
one, so, it's decision.
Is camera ready?
>> SVEN KIEFER: Ready?
[ Xylophone playing ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: It's not bad, huh?
You could clap one time for me.
that's okay this is
history, you know.
Sometimes it's like the
books in this house.
Some books are really old.
But this is history.
Today, a xylophone looks like that.
[ Applause ]
[ Xylophone playing ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Ready?
Okay, stand up.
For everybody.
Please, hang off the thing there.
Now we do something together.
You ready?
Do you know the wheels on the bus.
Wheels on the bus,
you know that song?
Let's try it together,
let's try it together.
Okay, deep breath.
[ Xylophone and kids
singing "Wheels on the Bus" ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Not bad.
But, let's try it again.
You're right, the bus
and the wheels okay.
okay, breath.
[ Xylophone and kids
singing "Wheels on the Bus" ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Okay, wait, I
will tell you something now.
now, take just a look to
me, just take a look to me.
pay attention.
I will show you what I see.
People, you sing like that.
Take a look.
The wheels on the bus go round
and round, round and round,
the wheels on the bus
go round and round all
through the -- Do you think good?
I get scared about this.
please give me a smile here.
Don't smile if you don't want
to smile, but give me smile.
You're ready for smile?
It's also for you back there.
Take me a smile, please.
We do it again, ready?
Okay? Take a deep breath.
[ Xylophone and singing,
"Wheels on the Bus" ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Okay,
now we get angry.
Close your arms together, make bad
face, now we make big bad wheels.
Ready for bad wheels on the bus.
Ready? Sure?
Bad wheels on the bus.
Take breath.
[ Xylophone and singing,
"Wheels on the Bus" ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Not bad.
But, let's do, I get scared of that.
Let's do a sad version
of wheels on the version.
You can do sad version.
Please keep your hands down
there, just hang around
and sad version go around.
Ready? Are you sure/
Take a big breath.
[ Xylophone and singing,
"Wheels on the Bus" ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: and this
is the job of musicians do
and musician tells you stories
about happy crazy things
and all this stuff.
And some of them, sometimes
in their story
that tells us about sleeping story.
Please, let's try something
very nice.
We go on the ground, on our back
and we watch through the roof
and we put off the
lights and then we try
to make sleep story, sleepy story.
Go on your back.
Go down. take a good
long, take a small rest.
Right on the back.
Move a little bit in the back,
otherwise you do not
have space enough.
Lie on your back, lie on your back.
We have to turn on your back.
Okay, grown up people, you can sit.
Lie on your back.
On your back.
Oh, my god, is that
difficult, oh, my god.
go on the back.
Could we turn off the light please.
Yeah. Okay.
we do not turn off the lights.
Okay, it's okay.
leave them,, leave them, it's okay.
it's okay.
leave them, leave them.
Take a seat, it's okay, it's okay.
fall on your back, go on your back.
Stay on your back.
Take a rest.
Hey guys, we did enough.
We make poopusvinken.
We saw a lot of things.
[ Xylophone playing, "Twinkle,
Twinkle Little Star" ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: Just take a rest.
>> SVEN KIEFER: We found the
rhythm in our heart today.
We saw a lot of things.
The story about the drums.
We were dancing.
Poopusvinken.
We are in the television now.
Some people yeah, wow.
You feel good?
You still lie on your back.
We going to travel on a big journey
to my country, because we have
to cross a big, big ocean.
I have the big ocean with me.
don't do that, don't do that.
Just take a look.
Stay there, I'm coming to everybody.
Lie on the ground.
>> SVEN KIEFER: I come
there, stay there.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Big boat, huh.
Sometimes on the ocean
a big wave comes.
>> SVEN KIEFER: Are you getting wet?
Oh, you do not get wet.
I don't think so.
Wow. Okay.
I will short, very short.
maybe it function now,
take a look, it's magic.
Oh, sometimes, there's problem.
You see, this is not French,
this is called Luxembourg.
And Luxembourg is the
language we speak.
Now I will say something
now in Luxembourg.
You listen.
[ Speaking in foreign language ]
>> SVEN KIEFER: It
sounds strange I think.
But it doesn't matter.
But this country is
that small, You see?
Come look.
One half hour to go there,
half hour to cross that.
We are 500,000 people
living in the whole country.
It's like Washington Center.
Downtown here, I think,
it's the same, huh?
So, thank you very much.
Good to be here.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.